[Music]
okay in honest glow-up news submitted by
Oreo cookies oh sorry
submitted by our Oreos cookies comedian
come on the judge digit okay I know come
on I just never say his Nast name right
shock the internet with his physical
transformation I saw this yo ya [ __ ]
jaw is he you guys who thinks he's buff
when he's not gym uh I don't know I
don't know him personally but I'm sure
he probably did that
no no just by the look I'm pretty sure
you did that I'm pretty sure you did I'm
pretty sure when he was at communion he
probably thought he looked hot I think
you're missing it his question his
question is you know I got friend Alec
yeah yeah it's fat right yeah but he's
his buff like Ronnie Coleman ah so I
said is this guy like Alec um like is he
fat like but then he looks buzz yeah
anyway Hugh used to look like this I
remember no no no he used to like worse
than that my buddy has a picture of him
getting into a hot tub and he was just
so he it's that sounds like how it looks
yeah yeah yeah it's very it's very it's
a thing but you know what's funny is
like he he talks about what he did in
his transformation it took him a year
with it with trainers and a lot yeah
it's like the reason why I mean not only
is the transformation crazy which like I
said this was before this is after Danko
he looks great it was pretty fast he
posted this on Instagram along with this
photo he was [ __ ] over he looks like
he's throbbing throbbing right before
this photo right before this photo there
this [ __ ] small clump and he wetted
himself down pretty good yeah don't get
jealous of course I am
get me two oh yeah I was like oh god
this is the terrible because not every
girl's gonna be like if he can do it so
he had this caption holy [ __ ] it says I
never thought I'd be one of those people
who would post a thirsty shirtless but
I've worked way too hard for way too
long so here we are you either die a
hero or you live long enough to see
yourself become the villain found out a
year ago I was going to be in Marvel's
eternals and decided I wanted to
transform how I looked I would not have
been able to do this if I didn't have a
full year with the best trainers and
nutritionist paid for by the biggest
studio in the world I'm glad I look like
this but I also understand why I never
did before it would have been impossible
without the these resources and time so
big thanks to someone who started
working with me at the beginning of the
year and made me understand true
physical pain for months and months then
once again we started shooting a massive
thanks to David Higgins and his team and
he added more people so all these
trainers for training me almost every
day and making me strong limber and
injury free I can almost touch my toes
now parentheses and thank you for
forcing me to do cheat meals David
Matthews Street catering for their
delicious and healthy meals and does
this full-on shot up our day which is
his wife for putting up with me
complaining and playing the Oscar music
dude come on right let me finish for
putting up hoods you complaining and
talking about only working out and
dieting for the last is important it's
the fact that you saying thanks is why
for supporting it
cut to the part about the wives shape
and they say Oh me I missed that this is
like people asking podcast for penis can
I tell you the best part about this
caption what is he he let us off the
hook
ok yes we got the guys back because
because he said in there I wouldn't have
been able to do this without a year and
a team and expensive studio doing this
yeah honey I'm not in the mall right
exactly you want to cast me the Marvel
movie that's not paid for all of this
expensive no I mean how much was the
cost of everything so if if someone
would want to replicate his team it
could easily be like 10,000 a month I
was gonna say it's probably a million
dollars you know I wouldn't be surprised
because if it's like a team of people
they have to get paid the full 24 hours
them all the two fishness know and then
then they're probably exclusive so it's
not like they have like other clients
they probably work you know I mean and
like they built a Jesse James spins like
goes something like over a million
dollars a year LeBron James these are
professional athletes a lot of money on
your body that's why Jeff Bezos is
ripped as [ __ ] I know but dual gauge
isn't why not what a [ __ ] it Jeff
Basil's surpass them right oh yeah
million dollars can't you build like a
robot machine where you just stick your
arms in it and their legs in it and it
just kind of moves you for you so you
don't really have to work out here go to
sleep
yeah that's like that no prejoh kits
like going over just have people move
her around which is so did you get their
makeup though she's sleeping so when she
wakes up it's ready to go yeah you sound
so envious no I mean sure I gotta wake
me up you think it's like Avatar so you
want a makeup slave that'll be pretty
cool though I it'll wake me up as soon
as the brush hits my face unless they're
super gentle and just like look working
out is so hard all right it's so
difficult every time I start a process
it's so a guy you don't see the results
that you want so when I hear this I see
this guy we all want to look like that
but then I hear what he says he needed
Marvel Studios he needed you know all
this stuff and I just go okay
I'm never gonna unless they let stay
want me to be in the next Marvel movie
you know let's do it I'm ready to start
the process but it's like damn that's a
lot how great would it be if he's just
wearing jackets and the internals I know
right character never takes his shirt
off reason I guess see like if I was him
though after all that he had to go
through every scene for no reason I'd be
taking my shirt yeah
or I'd be like flashing the teenagers
under they'll be like Kat Kat um why is
your shirt off again and they said
that's why it's what Ryan Gosling does
it off for no reason he looks more
jacked and Ryan goes yeah
that's actually right this is amazing
transformation ready to be like actual
like super healing Kathryn
what's-his-name from Jurassic Park and
uh you know guys Chris Pratt did the
same thing he went from like a dumpy you
know on what you got is next thing you
know you're like good how old is he it's
gotta be like 43 44 let me google that
cuz they don't tell me in this article I
heard something about like the comedian
world or some [ __ ] was like giving them
these two sexy let's grab my bucket no
that's that's just community we just
make him fun he knows he would do the
same thing okay it's a fun it's a fun
jealousy it's just good stuff out there
so you gotta roasted yeah that's all
that's all it is that's why people all
my friends are putting up pictures of
him from before but you know he's
winning though this is it's no believe
me this is not like women cuz y'all
would be tearing each other down like
we're way more supportive of each other
then y'all like you can't work the [ __ ]
off of her love a woman a kind of
transformation it'd be like you know but
there's no trainer in the world that can
get rid of you know a lot of the women
get that I'm around is by men most of it
I don't know about that
I think it's 50/50 it's insulate you
don't want to know but yeah it's pretty
it's all for men it's maybe women are
the most supportive wait wait wait
so the men that don't know you or these
women
cuz I'm talking about the women that
know you and know you the best that's
where you get the most hate from mm-hmm
man we were way more supportive of each
other and women we love women loved
loved ones we love women we tolerate
women because there's a thing that they
have that we want desperately so we a
beautiful life let me tell you something
he would trade if the choice was
beautiful life no [ __ ]
right or an aggie [ __ ] life but a lot
of [ __ ] gets me he's gonna pick those
are the only choices
what do you picked it nobody
[Laughter]
well I swear today we're gonna be here
for a while that's true
see I'm preserving my friendships what
I'm talking about right there and that's
what we do that's why we survive because
we go well I got to be with her here
with her so let me just not be truthful
okay what y'all do is y'all go yo you I
would just attack what I'm afraid of is
that cuz like if my wife looked like
Martha Washington I don't think I would
lose that well right so my wife look
like that in an argument maybe I'd be
like [ __ ] it [ __ ] you deuces you don't
need I'm afraid of that what do you mean
you're afraid of that
oh my Washington oh yeah well because I
know because what you're saying is
you're like the only reason why I'm here
is because you look like this so keep
your [ __ ] together because your attitude
is not it's your attitude your looks
outweigh the attitude once that [ __ ]
starts to even out
scary thoughts damn no that's something
that I've observed lately from people
around me from aging [ __ ] aging guys
actually so I've noticed that I have a
friend who's who's his dad left his mom
and for a very much younger chick
because he when they're in simple
argument was it was that's how it
happened like they're together they see
if he sees a younger chick and he left
her for her or they broke up and a
younger chick just seemed no no no no he
left their marriage which was like
30-year old marriage for a much much
younger was he having an affair like
usually like that's like a you know I
know but I'm going into the psychology
of that right so like why what I think
it's like it's like one of those things
works like I'm not gonna deal with this
[ __ ] anymore
there is something way more tempting
here visually and that's what I'm gonna
spend time trying to deal with you I'm
saying that's what comes with its own
complications right I'm not saying that
for myself but that's something that
it's a pattern that I've noticed people
doing like that is weird it is what it
is what you're supposed to say I mean
this is this is how we're designed
poorly yeah you know we just designed
called it I feel I I feel for women so
when people say God is a woman that's
[ __ ] because if God as a woman
that's proof that women hate women
because if you if you had to if you had
a design let's say you could go back and
be like you could be God like when you
change it all for women you'd be like
the period out that's gone yeah guys
would be pregnant but maybe it's proof
that God is a woman because she hates
women
period that's the most ever yeah cuz I
cuz it's just to make it like I always
feel like it like what if women didn't
get their period till they were 30 you
know how would the life how could you
sell us finally earn a living imagine if
you could get pregnant and not have any
complications into your 60s wouldn't
that change your life too oh yes that's
what I'm saying so it's like this is
what happens they have to deal with so
much and with their bodies and their
emotions and their hormones and us you
know we could be [ __ ] fifty-eight
[ __ ] you know we still get pretty
nuts it's some guy did it at 90 look at
Eddie Murphy Eddie Murphy you like he he
he just recently had a grandkid and he
just got his wife pregnant he likes to
come a lot he's [ __ ] up the family
tree
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]